welcome back everybody um
and uh
feel free to continue
okay great um so i think i fixed the
issue with the fees earlier let me just
say something really quick
so assuming i didn't make a mistake in
the fix um the problem was that we
wanted to apply uh fee to both sides of
this
um and there was a factor of two which
was offending us
so i
i think if you
well
in in our application of of uh
alfano's method we start with this
minimax risk we had expectation of l
which is written explicitly as p of rho
so i think if we move the two down to
the denominator and apply phi and then
just do the appropriate
algebraic manipulations because we can
apply markov with whatever we want
um then i think it all ends up working
out so we can massage things that we
have
rho is bigger than two delta which is
what we wanted so
what this ends up doing and i wrote it
in blue is before we had point four um
phi of two delta and now it becomes
point eight field delta so the good news
is that we can in fact apply this to
more than just um the loss function
being a metric being a semimetric
all right um
so going back to this local differential
privacy
and we have this monster expression here
um so what i want to do now is just go
through one example um
and
uh i think what what this example will
show is why this distance based notion
of final is useful so um
the kind of hinted at in order to prove
this theorem which we won't have time to
go through um the the two steps are to
use the distance
distance based version of fano and also
upper bound um the mutual information
using an appropriate quantity that
depends on alpha as well as some other
stuff
um but we could just use the not
distance based version of final right
like as long as we we make sure that we
start with the two delta separated set
things should be okay
um but
the reason for the distance based
version of fano is that it might be
easier to construct some sort of a set
which is a subset of our of our
distribution set which we don't enforce
to be
too delta separated just for the
computations so we'll see this in the
example that we're about to do
um and i'll
talk more about this this quantity i
guess uh this fee of v which is showing
up is probably mysterious because i
haven't had a chance to go through the
proof with you um but we'll at least
show how to evaluate it for the um the
set that we'll construct um to work on
okay so
and and my plan is to spend about 15
more minutes maybe at most on this and
then switch over to the computation to
finish it off so the example is
mean estimation
all right and we're going to depart a
little bit from our parametric
set
parametric classes that we we dealt with
earlier so here let script p
be the class
of p dimensional
distributions supported on a ball
supported on the ball of radius r in
euclidean norm
and we will show
that for
alpha between zero and one we have the
locally differential private risk
in squared two norm
is equal to omega of r squared p over n
alpha squared
okay
um
and
just a short note so maybe two remarks
um so this is achievable
using
a sampling mechanism
described in duchy
so i'm not going to go through the
details of it it's a bit complicated
even to state
um
i mean i can't just say this is
achievable using the sample mean like
you would expect because i mean you
could you would expect from the previous
lectures because the sample mean of
course is not going to be
locally differential private so what we
have to do is construct a way of
generating the zi's and then construct
an estimator based on the zi's and that
itself is rather complicated
but this lower bound is in fact
achievable but maybe the one thing to
to remark on that carries a bit of
information is that
comparing
this
to the
non-private
minimax risk
of
theta of
r squared
over n
the effective sample size
goes from being n to being an alpha
squared over
p
okay
so um this is is uh this is a smaller
quantity than n so because we want to
enforce privacy then we do in fact lose
something and rather than an additive
factor now it's a multiplicative effect
okay so let's discuss the the proof um
so
let
script v
um be the vertices
of the p-dimensional
hypercube
which is negative 1 plus 1 to the p
okay
and then
for v in script v define the
distribution
pv
such that
x distributed as pv is generated
by drawing an index
j in the set one through p
uniformly at random
and then
setting x to be equal to
r e j so e j is the canonical basis
vector with probability one plus
delta
v transpose e j
over two
and negative r e j
with probability one minus delta v
transpose e j over two
okay so this is um
this is a particular two point
distribution um
for each value of um
uh sorry it's it's not going to be a
two-point distribution because um
because x could be actually anything
of the two p possible values so
x takes values
in x equals plus or minus
r times e j where j goes from one to k
okay
so it's kind of um biasing the the
choice um it's biasing the values that
that x is taking according to um
according to the coordinates of v so for
every distribution on this or for every
uh
v in in this hypercube we have a
different distribution
right
um and
so note that
pv
is indeed supported
on
v2r
obviously because all the possible
values are going to be multiples of the
canonical basis vectors
okay and a couple other things to note
um so
now
note that so really this is the
construction and now what i'm going to
do is i'm going to calculate the various
quantities that are showing up in
infano's method we need to create we
need to calculate the the separation
function um
and the the size of the neighborhoods
so the first thing to note is that
expectation under pv of x is equal to
um it's one over p
times
r okay so if we wanted to look at just
the g or here i'm sorry
it's not what i want to say so note that
theta sub v which is the parameter that
corresponds to
the mean of the distribution
is equal to
delta r over p times v
and if you want to see this slowly then
if you look at the expectation under pv
of the jth coordinate
it's equal to one over p
times r times
1 plus
1 plus delta v transpose e
j
over 2
minus r times 1 minus delta b transpose
e j over 2 and you can check that this
is in fact equal to
delta
r v transpose e j over p
okay
um so now we need to look at these
separations um so
remember we have some sort of a metric
that's defined on the v's themselves so
let this
be the l1 distance
then for t bigger than zero
we have
the separation
function
is equal to well it was one half of the
minimum of the distance between the two
thetas when the two v's
when the metric between the v's was
bigger than t so if i square the one
half i get a one quarter
and we have a minimum of theta v minus
theta v prime two norm squared um
such that
v minus v prime in one norm is bigger
than z so just to reiterate um i can
define this um this metric that i'm
using to define distances between the
v's however i want i'm choosing it to be
the l1 distance um and the separation
function is one-half which i know square
of the distance in terms of
a row of the thetas
squared
okay and and because i have calculated
this thing up here i can conveniently
plug it down down there so this is equal
to r squared
delta squared over
4p squared
minimum of v minus v prime 2 norm
squared such that v minus v prime is
bigger than t
and then now i have a nice convenient
relationship between
one norms and two norms this is bigger
than or equal to r squared delta squared
over four p squared
times
t over square root of p squared which is
equal to r squared delta squared t
squared over four p cubed
okay so i've calculated my um my
separation function
now i need to calculate the neighborhood
size
so i can take whatever t i want
and for the rest of this we're going to
take t equals p over 6.
so you can calculate the neighborhood
size to be equal to the sum
s goes from 0 to t of
p choose s
um why is this well it's it's basically
because remember the neighborhood size
is in terms of the v's how close are
how many points are within some ball um
and and these v's are all on the
vertices of a hypercube so it's really
just you know it's a combinatorial
problem how many coordinates do i change
and you can bound this using standard
techniques this is bounded by
two peaches t
which is bounded by twice p e over t to
the t
um and this is equal to so plugging in
here the fact that um
that t is p over six we get some
cancellation and this is just two times
six e to the p over six
okay so what we're interested in is
um
log base two of the size of v over n t
that's what shows up in finals
inequality
and this is going to be bigger than or
equal to so the size of
v is 2 to the p
and we have
log of that is p
minus p over 6 log base 2 of
6 e minus 1 which is bigger than or
equal to some constant times p that's
what we want order of
okay
so we've calculated our um
our distance function our separation
function we've calculated this quantity
the number of points in the
set
rescaled by the neighborhood size and
now we need to worry about this monster
here
right so
so this thing so let's
i'm not going to do the calculation
completely i just want to say a couple
of things um
so
uh
maybe i will yeah let's go back down
here um
okay so next
we show that one over the size of v
times supremum over
the sky of sum
v and v v v
squared of gamma
is less than or equal to some constant
times delta squared over p
okay and the way we do this is um
by writing
um the left-hand side
as a quadratic form
in gamma um what's gamma well gamma is a
function
so
note that
gamma which was in
a function defined on script x
can be represented
as a vector
in r to the 2p
okay so um so this notation here means
that it's a bounded function defined on
the space of x and remember that x
itself could only take on two p possible
values right they were all these um plus
or minus our ejs
so
i can write out the the
like represent a function as a two p
dimensional vector which just tells me
what every coordinate is
um
and it turns out that um actually well i
should say if you ignore this supremum
part this quantity here can be written
as a quadratic form in gamma um so how
do we do this well roughly speaking so
we have
so here's rewriting the definition of
phi v this is expectation under pv of
gamma of x
minus 1 over
the psi so this is sort of the average
value
expectation under pv of
gamma of x
okay
um so this is the definition
and
now
you can calculate
that expectation under pv of gamma of x
well what's that well it's the sum j
goes from one to p so this is just by
directly writing out what it means to be
an expectation so the value is either r
ej or r minus ej
the probability is 1 over p times 1 plus
delta v transpose e j over two
plus gamma of negative r e j and the
probability of that is one over p
one minus delta v transpose
e j over 2.
okay so this is just by directly writing
out what this guy is
so then by our construction
of
script v we can also check that
phi v of delta
of gamma is equal to
delta over 2 p
times the summation of
j goes from 1 to p
gamma of r pj times
v transpose bj
minus gamma of negative r e j times v
transport v
okay so what is where is this coming
from it's not actually that mysterious
so my claim was that um
was that we can actually transform
this sum of the squares as
a quadratic form and gamma so what we
would really like is if we can write um
this guy phi v of gamma as gamma
transpose something right we want an
inner product of gamma and something
else so we write down what the first
quantity is and we we have something
that looks almost like an inner product
of gamma and something
well i mean it is so it's a sum of of
gamma on each of the coordinates
multiplied by something else
um but we're going to be it would be
really nice if we could get rid of these
extra terms because what we really want
is to
write this as we'll write it here and
then erase it we want it to be gamma
transpose times
something times v that would be really
nice
um and actually the
the convenient thing is that the terms
that that are in our way they get
eliminated when i subtract out the mean
over all the v's that's what i'm writing
here so to get from
from here to here i'm just preserving
the terms
gamma of r e j and this delta term i
took out the delta and
and the two and the p okay
so i have that um and
and then you can write this we'll define
this as delta over 2p times gamma
transpose a times v
let's get rid of that okay so now um
well then
um
what do i want well i want
well okay so i i wanted to calculate uh
i want to be normalized but i need to
sum up over the v's and normalize by the
size of v
um
and
then by by our construction um we also
have
1 over the size of v
sum v in v
of v v transpose is equal to the
identity matrix
by our construction
and this is important so this is because
when we were uh when we were creating
this set we chose these um terms v to be
on the vertices of the hypercube so you
see that if we had to constrain
the vectors v so that we had some
separation between
any pair of distributions
then we might not have these nice
properties that we can just sort of you
know that we can we can d mean uh this
quantity when we subtract
that and that we can just make the v's
evaporate
okay
so
overall
we can bound
the summation of
vv of gamma squared
let's put a 1 over v in front of it
using spectral properties
of the matrix a okay so if you actually
write out what is this
matrix a that that falls out of this
representation then it's a very simple
matrix and you'll find that the things
cancel out so overall we end up with a
bound on the order of
delta squared over p
you can see that sort of if you square
this guy you have a delta squared over p
squared and the reason why a p gets
knocked off is because um we're taking a
supremum over
gammas which are bounded in infinity
norm and when we talk about structural
properties of a matrix we're bounding it
rebounding quadratic forms where gamma
is a unit vector
okay but um we won't dwell on this
longer
so
oops we need to do that
so combining the results
we finally have r sub
r sub ldp
of
r
two norms squared and alpha should be
equal to omega of so we need to take our
um
what is it so we need to take our our uh
our separation function um
that's the first thing that shows up
take a separation function
um so we have an r squared
delta squared
p squared
over
c
over p cubed
times 1 minus n
e to the alpha minus 1 squared times
constant
delta squared over p
over c p
i guess there's an extra factor of
p that shows up
um
oh all right
r squared delta squared oh yeah okay
sorry um so we uh so our separation
function was r squared delta squared t
squared over 4p cubed
and we chose t to be of the order of p
if you remember t was p over 6. so all
together we get r squared delta squared
p squared over 4p cubed which is what
i've written here and then the bound has
1 minus this guy
here
this is the bound that we just derived
um
from up here
and then we had
a bound on the log of the of the set
which was cp
okay so
put it all together
this is omega of r squared delta squared
over p times 1 minus
3c prime alpha squared
and
delta squared over cp squared
since
e to the alpha minus 1 quantity squared
is bounded by 3 alpha squared for alpha
between 0 and 1.
and
then so now we play the the usual game
how do we make this order of um one-half
then we take
delta squared to be on the order of
p squared over alpha squared n
so r ldp
is going to be equal to omega of
r squared p over alpha squared
okay so we're done
um all right so hopefully this wasn't
too laborious but um i hope that this
this kind of illustrates well first of
all of course how you would get these um
lower bounds for local differential
privacy but also what the benefit is of
using the distance-based tano method
where you can
just define this uh
the subset of distributions however you
want
okay
um
and maybe one final note before i go to
uh computation um i just wanted to say
that there's one other method that i'm
aware of for bounds
on estimators that
satisfy privacy so
another method
for establishing lower bounds
under dp
is using
a method of tracing attacks
and this is
[Music]
work that's been pioneered by dork at
all 2015
and the idea
is to construct
an algorithm
which can detect
the absence or presence
of a data point
x
in the target
set x
by
looking at an estimator
theta hat of x
and
this might be possible
if theta out of x is accurate enough
providing
a lower bound on the accuracy
of private estimators
okay so um if we have the guarantee of
privacy that means that um that nobody
should be able to tell based on data
whether or not a point a particular data
point is in your
in your set
so just just very very briefly um
to give you an idea of it so this method
has been used
in the statistical literature
by tai at all
in 2020
to study
high dimensional
private mean estimation
and also linear regression
okay and as an example
actually this is an oversimplified
example what would
a tracing attack look like
so a tracing attack
for mean estimation
might look something like this
a sub mu of
x
theta hat capital x so this is supposed
to tell us
whether or not
the datum little x was used to construct
theta hat of x and if we define this to
be equal to x minus mu inner product
with theta hat of x
okay
then
this succeeds
if theta hat of x
is close to the empirical mean
so this is sort of a massive
oversimplification but um you can
imagine that if you replace this
estimator by the sample mean um then if
little x is equal to one of well if it's
not equal to one of the x i's um then
then this will be very close to zero um
however if little x happens to be one of
the x i's then we have a then we can
detect a correlation that x is present
in the data now of course this is only
true if theta hat is exactly equal to
the mean however this also tells us that
if theta hat is close enough to the mean
then this tracing attack should be able
to succeed in um
in telling you whether or not little x
is there and therefore violate privacy
and therefore um a private estimate
cannot be too close to the mean and
therefore cannot be too close to um to
the true mean mu
okay
so
that's that so now in the final half
hour or so um let's see how much time
i've given myself um to talk about
computation
that's a good question go ahead
yeah so i'm curious
so this works even in situations where
thanos inequality
tails
um
i i haven't looked in too much detail
but i think that this might lead to
tighter bounds than thanos inequality
would
um but i haven't specifically tried to
check what finals inequality would do in
these particular cases
very cool thanks
great um so
lastly we have computation and as i said
i'm going to
be a bit brief here because i think a
lot of the other talks are in
computation and
secondly i'm not really a complexity
theorist so um
yeah so i'll just kind of give big big
picture ideas of what the result here is
what the result is here and also what
the ideas of the proof are
okay so the reference that we're going
to go off of is um zhang wainwright and
jordan this is yu chin zhang's work from
a couple years back
and the paper is
lower bounds on the performance
of polynomial time algorithms
for sparse linear regression
and this is a paper from 2014.
okay so um this is kind of bringing us
full circle to the first lecture when we
talked about linear regression and we
had lower bounds
so the problem set up
is that we have a linear model
y equals x theta plus w
where w is this independent gaussian
noise
and x is fixed
okay and we
assume
that the true theta is in r to the p
and is
k sparse
okay
so we are
we are looking at
the minimax risk which is in the
prediction error
enthemum over theta hat supremum over
all sparse vectors
of one over n expectation of
x theta hat minus x theta two norm
squared
okay
that look a little bit nicer
okay
so this work
shows that the risk
is strictly larger or the minimax risk
is strictly larger
when theta hat
is constrained
to the class of polynomial time
estimators
okay
um i should also say when
x comes from a certain class of agencies
okay so as i um in the first lecture we
went through a lower bound and i said
that in fact it's achieved when um when
we use the lasso estimator which is
certainly a polynomial time estimator um
the point now is that we're going to
relax the conditions on x that we had
imposed in the first lecture
um so just to make a couple more
comments before i state the theorem so
an upper bound
of the form
order of
sigma squared k
log p over n
can be achieved
by taking the estimator
theta hat is equal to the argument
over theta in the sparse ball
so look at all k sparse vectors y minus
x theta 2 norm squared
and this is the result of
bounia
at all
2007
but the estimator
is computationally intractable
because it involves
searching over all possible
sparse vectors
so instead we often consider the lasso
estimator theta hat is equal to arg min
over theta in rp
of
1 over n
y minus
x theta 2 norm squared plus lambda
theta 1 where we choose lambda
appropriately
um
so now this ends up doing well as long
as x is a well-conditioned matrix so to
kind of reiterate these ideas
so let gamma of x denote
the restricted eigenvalue
or in high dimensional statistics speak
re condition
oh sorry constant
this is a the function of x rather than
a condition
constant of the matrix x so this means
that gamma of x
is the largest
gamma
such that 1 over n times x theta 2 norm
squared is bigger than or equal to
gamma theta 2 norm squared
for all theta which are in a particular
set
and this set is the union over all
subsets of size
k
of this cone set
c of s
where c of s is equal to
theta
in
oops imagine what happened
theta in
rp
such that
theta sc
this is the l1 norm on the
on the elements that are not in s is
less than or equal to
theta s
okay so this is a bit of a mouthful but
this is kind of um this standard theory
for those of you who work in high
dimensional statistics so you want um
it's kind of like a sparse eigenvalue
lower condition and that's how we stated
it in the first lecture when we impose
conditions on x
so you certainly want that x is well
conditioned when you multiply it by
sparse vectors
but this set is a little bit bigger than
just all the case parse vectors so the
case bars vectors would certainly have
the one norm of the off support guys
less than the one norm on everything
everything else because this is equal to
zero but we have a slightly bigger set
here and we want this to hold here
okay
um so under
an upper bound so under what's called
the column normalization
condition
which is x theta
two norm squared over n is less than or
equal to theta two norm squared
for all
sparse vectors now here we're in the 2k
ball
the lasso satisfies
the upper bound supremum over
all k sparse vectors
1 over n
expectation of
x theta hat minus x theta 2 norm squared
is less than or equal to constant over
gamma squared x
sigma squared k log p over
okay so um
so just to contrast these two guys so
the upper bound that i stated earlier
here
for the computationally intractable
estimator has a sigma squared k log p
over n
lasso does as well
but we have to assume that it's well
conditioned or at least the theory holds
under an assumption that the restricted
eigenvalue constant is not too small so
the way that we stated it in the first
lecture was we said that there was some
constant lower bound on the sparse
eigenvalues so you can kind of think
about it like this too so the guarantees
of the lasso get worse if um if x is
badly conditioned
and
you know why do we think about this as
um as not necessarily a constant well um
let me just remind you so x is in um
r to the uh n by p
um and if you think about x as being
drawn from some ensemble let's say
normal zero sigma
um then gamma of x is kind of like the
minimum
eigenvalue
of sigma
and you can make the minimum eigenvalue
of sigma get smaller and smaller as the
problem grows
okay so the question um that that we
want to ask
is
do computational
do computationally tractable estimators
exist
which in which avoid
the factor
of gamma of x in the denominator
okay
and the main result is that the answer
is no
so this is the result of
john it all
right so
so sort of colloquially
the extra factor
of gamma of x is
actually it's a little bit stronger than
that the extra factor of one over gamma
squared of x is unavoidable
in all
polynomially polynomial time estimators
assuming
a particular conjecture and complexity
theory which is that np
is not a subset of p poly
okay
and
p poly is
the set of problems
solvable
in polynomial time
with the help of an advice string
which can depend on
the length of the input
i should say with the help of uh and is
polynomial in length
okay so just a tiny bit about the
complexity theory um so so p is the is a
set of problems that are solvable in
polynomial time um it turns out that p
is actually um a subset but not um is a
strict subset of p poly so there are
some more problems in in the set p poly
um because in addition to uh to being
well so so p means that it has to be
polynomial time just in the inputs p
poly gets some side information so
there's a precomputed string that um
that that it can use as an input as a
side input based on the size of your
problem
um so it is
i'm not going to go into too much detail
here so so this is known
and
and this is conjectured
okay
um so assuming that this is true we have
the following result
theorem says that
consider
any polynomial time algorithm
which outputs
uh
k sparse
estimator
theta hat
then
for any delta in
0 1
and gamma sufficiently small
there exists
npk
and a matrix
x in r to the n by
p such that and here i'm being a little
bit loose
so gamma of x is going to be
approximately equal to gamma
and supremum
over
all sparse vectors of one over n
expectation of
x theta hat minus x theta 2 norm squared
is lower bounded by a constant over
gamma squared
times sigma squared k to the 1 minus
delta
log of p
over n
okay so a couple remarks um
so the first remark is that we will
write this down
um
so the first remark is that uh
gamma can be chosen arbitrarily small
okay and this falls out of the proof
although the proof is rather complicated
and then
if
gamma and k
are fixed
[Music]
construction
of a bad matrix x
exists
or
exists
um n and p sufficiently large
so it's not just saying that there
exists a particular dimensionality that
works in fact any dimensionality bigger
than that will work um and then the
other remark is that
since delta is between 0 and 1
is arbitrary
the right hand side
can be made
well maybe not exactly arbitrarily but
quite close to
um
k squared right now k squared to k log p
over n which is um what we got from uh
from the lasso
um
i i should put
the gamma in there too
over
gamma squared
okay
um
i feel like there was one more thing i
wanted to say but maybe not
so this is saying that um so so in some
sense this
yeah question i'm sorry yeah so i guess
one remark
meaning to say this but um
the condition that theta had as k sparse
is important for for the result and i
believe it's still
totally open whether there exists an
estimator of theta hat without the
restriction that is k sparse that
achieves a good rate
yeah um i so i was reading up on this
last week and i saw a follow-up paper
from a year or two later i can't
remember who the authors were but they
were studying that problem i don't
really know what what the conclusion was
um at least yeah as of the time of this
paper it was certainly a restriction i
think there was at least one paper that
attempted to relax that
yeah
um
okay so and then maybe the last remark
because you might be wondering what does
this mean approximately equal to so i'm
not going to go into the details of this
but um in some sense you have to be a
little bit more careful than i'm even
going to talk about um so when you you
talk about a polynomial time algorithm
it's in the length of your input um but
these are all real valued matrices so we
need to do some discretization in order
to to represent it as a bit string
um and this is kind of with respect to
the discretization so we can make it as
close as we want with respect to the
discretization that we we use to make
this rigorous
um okay so my goal in the next again
we have a quick question oh sure
so uh we can do clarify the quantifier
over okay i mean because in the term
statement it seems that
for every government that exists okay
but then later on you say the training
six government okay
can i
um
yeah uh i don't know or can
or can you get the lower back for any
government okay just uh choosing the key
large enough
um so i don't remember the details of
the proof well enough but um definitely
for every gamma there exists a k and for
both of those there exists n and p
larger i mean if n and p are large
enough as a function of gamma and k then
it's true
but yeah i i don't i don't quite
remember um uh whether it's it's for all
k or just a particular k
yeah
thank you okay um good so now in the
last 15 minutes i'm just going to give
you sort of broad strokes what the what
the idea of the proof is
um
okay so the idea of the proof is to
um so consider
a particular
np hard
problem
involving
solving a linear system
to a certain
accuracy and
the np hard problem
is
a linear algebraic version
of the
exact
three-set cover problem
okay and the exact reset cover problem
is the following
given an integer
m greater than equal to 3
a set s
which is defined as 1 up to m
and a collection
script c of three element
subsets of s
to find m over three subsets
which
exactly cover
s assuming such a cover exists
okay so um this is known to be an np
hard problem which means that it's as at
least as hard as all the hardest
problems in the class np
um and
a solution
so first i'm going to use words and then
i'll state things a little bit more
explicitly so a solution to the linear
system
can then be used
to obtain a solution
of the exact cover problem
and then the np hardness
of the letter
together with the conjecture that np is
not
contained in the poly
implies
a lower bound
on the prediction error
of any
polynomial time algorithm
okay and this is um the prediction area
of any polynomial time algorithm um
which solves uh which solves this linear
system that's used for exact cover um
and then the last step is
then
we construct
a design matrix
x
such that um
accurately
or i'll just say such that
small prediction error
for
solving the system
x x theta
oh i should say design a matrix x and
also theta such that small prediction
error for the system xx theta
implies
small prediction error
for the exact cover system
okay so that's roughly where we're going
um solving this linear algebraic version
of the exact cover problem is going to
be hard so we have a lower bound of the
prediction error we'll show how to go
from the exact cover problem to the
original
high dimensional regression problem and
bound the prediction error of the first
by the second so just a couple more
details um
okay so here's some more details
there's this first lemma
and the dilemma says
given an integer
m
let l be equal to m choose three
then we can construct and this is an
explicit construction
a matrix m
which is in
negative 1 0
1 to the
m plus 3 l by 4 l
and an associated set of vectors
script v is equal to the set of v and r
to the
m plus 3l
such that
v is equal to mu
for some
u in the set
0 1 to the 4 l intersect
the sparse ball
and we'll denote this as
u
um
such that
the following problem is np hard
given any vector
v in script b
compute
u in script u
such that m u minus v is bounded by one
half
okay so this is the linear algebraic
problem that if we can solve this to the
desired accuracy which ends up being one
half um then this then what can be
extracted from this is a solution to the
exact cover problem
and i won't go through the details of
this um
the point is that the same matrix m
works regardless of the set cover
problem
okay
um
so
i'll just say here that
np hardness
comes from
the fact
that
any set cover problem
s script c
can be used
to construct
a response vector
um
u
and x i mean predicted
okay i just mean vector
because that's the prediction vector and
you can use construct a vector
u in script u
and the
related vector v equals
m u
such that an approximate solution
of the linear system
would solve the set cover
so now i have a linear algebraic problem
which is um
which is an npr problem okay so then the
next lemma is the following
um so i'm writing this in a little bit
more concreteness
so let f g
and h be arbitrary
polynomial functions
then for an integer
m 0 bigger than or equal to 1
there exists
m bigger than m0
and a distribution
let's call it q
over the set of
u
such that any solver
u hat
which can be encoded
in f m bits
and terminates
in g of m time
satisfies probability that u is coming
from u
m u
hat minus mu
2 norm less than one half is bounded by
one over h
okay so here i'm being a little bit more
explicit um really you can think about u
hat which can be encoded in f of bits
and terminates in g of the time as our
notion of a polynomial time algorithm
um
this is remember we want to the hard
problem was solving the exact cover
problem to an accuracy accuracy of one
half
and this says that there's some ensemble
over the set of possible u's so that um
their the probability of being accurate
is going to be as small as we want it to
be and the important thing here is that
the same ensemble cue
works for any algorithm you had okay so
i mean
um because it's an np-hard problem then
for any estimator for any algorithm you
have there should be some hard instances
and this result says that in fact um
there are some hard instances that are
hard for any you have
and um the proof here
um depends on
the
np is not a subset of p poly conjecture
so i won't go through the details here
either i guess this is very much in the
complexity theorist side of things
um and and basically um because of well
assuming that this conjecture is true
then we can turn the np hardness
statement about a deterministic problem
into a probabilistic statement
so then the last bit
which i'm just going to highlight
briefly
is
finally
for any x
and any estimator
theta hat we write the bound
um supremum over
all k sparse vectors
and now this is the quantity that we
were after in the first place
this is bigger than or equal to so now
we're going to take an expectation over
a particular
set so
this is
r theta is distributed as q
of
x theta hat minus x theta two norm
squared
okay so um
maybe i should say this is sort of a
double expectation
um so
so on the left hand side we're looking
at a supremum over um over all possible
choices of theta and here we're saying
that the supremum is lower bounded by an
average and in the average we're drawing
theta randomly from an ensemble
and then there's also the original
expectation which was over the
generation of
the response vector y which leads to
randomness of theta hat this is a double
expectation but we're really bounding
this agreement by an average and the
reason why we can do this is that we
need theta to be k stars um and the way
that we defined
the the set u for which q is defined
is that it's actually also going to be a
k star this is a sparse set the sparsity
is m over three plus l
so this holds um
if k is at least m over three plus l
okay so we have this lower bound here
um and and what's the r for this is just
a scaling factor which will be
determined or which is which is chosen
later
um and maybe the other thing to say is
r uh is related to gamma
okay so i mean i i want this to hold for
any case for our specters so of course
if i scale them by anything i want it's
okay
um
and
uh and and remember the statement of the
theorem was that i have a fixed gamma
and i want to construct an x such that
gamma of x is approximately gamma and
and the lower bound also holds okay so
um lastly um
we show how to construct or i won't show
you but it's in the paper so construct x
in
r to the n by p
from m and gamma
such that first of all gamma of x should
be approximately equal to gamma and
secondly um
let's say this is i and this is i i um
the right hand side
of let's call this star
can be lower bounded
by the prediction error of the
um
the prediction error of the problem that
involves you
okay so we have a way of um of
constructing um x from m i mean some
sort of uh block matrix construction
where there are lots of m's living
inside of it
um and uh and and one can show that um
with this construction we can lower
bound um
this guy by this guy and that's
approximately true there are some other
things um that are hiding here so
there's going to be well this is true
for of course
any any algorithm you had
and also there's some pre-factor that
depends on n p k and r okay so finally
um and i know this is kind of loose so
finally we lower bound expectations by
probabilities right so some version of
markov's inequality
then allows us to lower about the
expectation by this probability of error
so then use the lemma
to lower bound the last expectation
okay and if you're curious well
you know we were looking for a bound
that was of the form um
k times log p over n so that's coming
out of this part the k times log p over
n
we're also expecting a gamma squared to
show up in the denominator well in some
sense um
r times theta corresponds to u and so
what comes out of all this is an extra
factor of one over r squared and that
one over r squared roughly is what gives
you the one over gamma squared
okay so that's what i wanted to say
about this proof so just to review um
the the main steps as i had outlined up
above were to look at this
np-hard problem
of the exact cover problem to turn it
into a linear system
and the linear system
looks like this so we solve the problem
of mu minus v
up to desired accuracy and because of
the np hardness of the exact cover
problem this problem has to be hard so
the probability of having
a prediction error bounded by one half
should be small
and then we need to turn we need to find
a way to go from this linear system to
constructing a linear system
involving where we design x
and we need
the the
restricted eigenvalue constant to be
close to gamma
and then the last part is to relate the
two prediction areas so i'll stop here
and happy to take any questions
great thanks um any questions that i can
like to
ask her hey i have a question it's can
you hear me it's adam
hey pulling thanks for your talks
they're very thorough um
does this lower bound rule out say an
algorithm that has running time like k
squared log n or you know anything
larger than k like k log k log n or
um
running time or you mean uh
uh
or sample complexity yeah you mean the
the sound here right yeah
like you could still hope for you know k
log k or something i guess right
yeah yeah that's true yeah
okay and then just a a more of a comment
other than a question but i think like
the example you gave about
gaussians being ill-conditioned i think
for the specific case of gaussians
um you actually have we have upper
bounds on the sample complexity that are
independent of the of the condition
number because like the gaussianity
actually buys you something there and
you can hope for we don't have efficient
algorithms for that yet but but the but
the sample complexity is independent of
the of the condition number of the
covariance matrix
i see
um
so it doesn't doesn't this you know
doesn't uh contradict anything you've
written it's just for the example you
gave for calcium i don't think these
bounds apply but i guess i was just
giving an example of how the um
the the bound um the gamma of x quantity
could get small as n and p grow
right right
right and so i mean if you just it's
true that if you have well i mean like
if you if you look at gaussians which
are distributed according to um to uh
like an ensemble like this and you make
the minimum eigenvalue of um
of uh
of sigma go to zero with p then wouldn't
that cause this guy to get smaller yeah
no it so it that's the interesting thing
for the case of gaussians
of course that factor does get smaller
and smaller but
you can prove an upper you can still
prove an upper bound on the simple
complexity that's not dependent on that
term i see i think
okay yeah i'm not aware of that work but
i should i should read it later anyway
sorry
thanks for your talks
thanks adam for the questions any other
questions
all right well um i feel free of course
to the message uh to link with further
questions uh offline and and uh let's
thankfully again for a great series of
lectures
[Applause]
great so we'll see everybody back here
in a couple of hours